c'est dans les locaux de l'ot et rieux
que l'on étudie le marché immobilier
d'entreprise en ile de france
chaque année trois études en moyenne ils
sont réalisés
l'observatoire a constaté qu'avec un
parc de 50 3 millions de mètres carrés
de bureaux
l'île de france est première d'europe
mais l'offre a besoin d'être modernisé
l'attractivité économique en
ile-de-france aujourd'hui un petit peu
pénalisé par l'offre de qualité voilà
donc on n'est plus dans le
renouvellement que dans la construction
aujourd'hui le parc et le parc de
bureaux parisien est assez obsolète en
partie obsolètes donc pu tourner dans la
modernisation du parc qui permettra
d'avoir une offre de qualité et de
pouvoir répondre aux besoins des
entreprises notamment locales mais aussi
internationale dans les yvelines c'est
dans les années 90 que l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines s'est
affirmé comme un pôle d'affaires
dynamique
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien après la
défense une preuve que l'agglomération
conserve de nombreux atouts pour les
entreprises d'abord la proximité de la
capitale puisque saint quentin est situé
à 20 kilomètres de paris
c'est aussi on l'a dit le tissu
dynamique les entreprises des grands
noms des grandes sociétés des tpe
innovantes des laboratoires de recherche
un pôle université très dynamique est
également des logements le développement
des transports mais aussi l'intégration
de saint quentin en yvelines au cluster
paris saclay devrait permettre à
l'agglomération de renforcer son
attractivité dans les années à venir